up next we've got Brandon Bayer oh I got
nipples could you melt me [ __ ]
I got a debate question for you guys
today you get in a fight and you [ __ ]
your nose up you can see my shits going
off to the right get face surgery or
just leave it Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz
buzz dude you don't [ __ ] with the nose
you don't mess with the nose it changed
your look for the rest your life
you look like [ __ ] Val Kilmer machine
Val Kilmer lately it's tough dude it's
tough your boys had some snow surgeries
you've gotta leave that [ __ ] also no one
wants your boys who's my boy you see
your boys call me surgery I'm your boy
you had some oh yeah to reinstructive no
surgery you had to nose job you not
Hollywood nose jobs reconstructive nose
jobs matter of fact I've been taught
I've been talking about getting you a
deal on one really yes that's just
taking a little bit off later brah you
need a two-car garages you want me to
breathe around if your nose is broken
dude you know pray on it I think what
what about a Breathe Right strip look
pretty cool yeah but if they almost get
a really light rope to kind of hold it
over against one a year really you know
you'd have to almost uh lock it into and
the problem is when dudes touch their
face they all look exactly the same
you've had to nose jobs dude not like
what he's going for though he's going
forward the looks nose it seems like
what he broke his nose would you get it
for broken nose shattered this guy why
am I the one right now cuz you got a
fucked-up mouth
dude the guy's shitty tattoos this could
be you hey rewind it let me see how bad
his noses it's not bad no I didn't
looked like there's an issue just
septums on got a debate question for you
guys today
you're getting a fight and you [ __ ] your
nose up you can see my shits going off
to the right if they surgery depth them
or just leave it
gang game buzz buzz gang for a face
surgery let me say look up like this I'm
see yours that left nostril that left
nostril to fit a grape in bro I put a
grape in it yeah I know yeah small one
yeah nothing frozen is out huh oh dude
here bro do you can put mail in there
dawg Haley
yeah cuz one of the better and small
this one's large yeah well my name is
Annie owner Eva isn't even on center did
you break it huh no there's just like
something inside like there's like some
bad scar tissue inside that kind of
pulls it from the inside
um I don't know probably childhood
violence you know I don't know but the
man went in there they tried to they cut
they tried to cut some of it out but
some of us stayed in there oh damn so
cuz I remember for like two days my nose
was just kind of it was straight and
then it s just grew back or whatever and
I was like holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
crazy
but this guy dude I think you're fine
broad thing first of all I don't think
you had a problem
yeah I don't think you need a shirt I
don't think you need a nose job I don't
think you need anything maybe you're a
David you got a fog in you got a tattoo
what is that it a bird no it's a snake
it's two snakes oh you got two snakes I
was thinking the same thing yeah you're
fine are you going to heaven dude so I
would chill out man I pull over and get
some rest I think honestly yeah you look
pretty tired I'm super white teeth I'd
get more tattoos and still say [ __ ] the
nose
here's your the nose dude dude yeah if
you get another tattoo nobody then it
fits yes you know I think you've you
ever broken nose and you keep it you got
to have like six tattoos to offset it
let's laugh so my tattoos my face looks
like [ __ ] distraction distraction the
art distraction damn yeah something like
holy [ __ ] who I'm looking at for a while
yeah this morning I'm like oh cool meg
Ryan that's cool what else do you hide
62% of people went with never touch your
face
[Music]
the king
[Music]